Larry Krasner wants to fix America's
criminal justice system, which
imprisons more people per capita
than any other country on the
planet.
Since 2018, he served
as the district attorney of
Philadelphia, one of America's
most highly incarcerated
and as of late, increasingly
crime ridden cities.
Krasner spent three decades
as a criminal and civil rights
defense attorney before deciding to
run for office.
Our movement did the uncomfortable
thing. We took back power,
he wrote in a memoir about his
successful 2017 run
for Philadelphia's district
attorney.
We outsiders went inside
and took over the institution we
had fought against all our lives.
In his first week as D.A.,
Krasner fired 31 staffers
and replaced them with a new team
that he described as ideologically
attached to the mission.
It's a pretty basic mission for
people who are in favor of freedom.
One of those missions is to be
less incarcerated than Vladimir
Putin's Russia.
I don't think that should be very
controversial. Apparently it is.
But it seems to me that that's
basic. Another aspect of the mission
is not to have
what I would call the ultimate form
of big government, which is to be
the most incarcerated country in the
world without a perceptible
increase in safety.
Krasner easily won reelection
last year, but today he's
under intense pressure
because Philly posted a record 562
murders in 2021,
and it's on pace for a similar
outcome in 2022.
The Republican led state legislature
has begun impeachment proceedings
against him.
Reason sat down with Krassner in
his office to talk about his
reforms.
The violent crime spike, the
heat that progressive prosecutors
are feeling in cities like Los
Angeles and San Francisco,
and what that means for the future
of the American criminal justice
reform movement.
You spent decades
as a basic civil rights defense
attorney, and
now you are the city's top
prosecutor.
What made you decide to
pursue that in 2017?
You know, when I came out of law
school, I think I was a little bit
naive. And I believed
that if you just did really good
work, either as a prosecutor or
defense attorney.
I actually started out as a state
public defender in that
under-resourced rodeo
that Justice Sotomayor talked so
much about.
I believe that if you were on either
side, you could do really good work
and that the system wasn't
broken. But what I found out over 30
years is that in many ways it really
is. And those were the same 30
years when much
of the rise of mass incarceration
occurred.
So I got to the point when I was 56
where I felt like in order to have a
much more sweeping impact on
a system that I thought was
profoundly broken, I
had to do something else.
And that's when I decided to run to
be a chief prosecutor in Philly.
And can you talk a little bit about
Philadelphia specifically?
Because I know that, for instance,
the youth incarceration
rate was
high compared to even other big
American cities.
I mean, what was the situation that
you were coming into in
this city that you felt was needing
to be urgently addressed?
So crazy irony of Philly is
that this is
a tourist destination for freedom.
Liberty Bell, you know the place
where they wrote the Declaration of
Independence, the Constitution, all
of that is here. And yet when we
came into office, it was
the most incarcerated of the big
cities. It was the poorest of the
big cities. It had the highest level
of supervision on probation and
parole, 25 times higher rate
than New York City.
When we came in here and yet it is a
majority minority city and it's also
a city that's about 85% Democratic
and arguably
the poorest and the most violent
of the ten biggest cities, most
chronically violent, anyway, at that
time. So how the hell did you
end up with this witch's brew?
How is everything so bad all at
the same time?
That's when we came in, and
that was the mission we faced.
And part of the mission was
trying to figure out how you unravel
that, that unique combination of
economic failure that seems
connected to criminal justice
policies that don't make you safer
and that tear the city down.
That was the mission's big mission.
We've made, I think, some
significant progress
while simultaneously slamming into
the pandemic, which has been a
challenge all across the country.
Some reforms that you implemented
coming in that will probably sound
pretty good to a libertarian
audience, such as basically
not, uh, declining to prosecute
marijuana crimes,
opioid possession,
sex work type crimes.
You know what what libertarians
would call victimless crimes.
What were you hoping to achieve
with that policy and how
has it panned out so far from?